WHICH, YOU KNOW WHAT, IS
REFRACTION.
GREAT SHOW, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANKS, MAN.
>> Sean: BUCKLED UP, WELCOME
TO "HANNITY," THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE MAJOR
DEVELOPERS TO BRING YOU,
INCLUDING PROOF THAT COMEY'S
DEEP STATE OF ALLSPICE SPIED ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AN ADMISSION FROM UKRAINIAN
EMBASSY, IN FACT OF THE DNC DID
TRY TO COLLUDE WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT DURING THE 2016
ELECTION.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE EVIDENCE.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU HOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS UNRAVELING
RIGHT BEFORE YOUR EYES,
LAWMAKERS AND PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES ALIKE LITERALLY
MELTING DOWN BECAUSE THEY ARE
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
COLLUSION FANTASY IS OVER.
ANYTHING FROM HERE ON IS JUST
NOISE, NOTHING MORE NOISE, THE
WITCH HUNT IS DONE, MUELLER HAS
GONE HOME, NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
THEY LOST, THEY LIED, THEY
CONSPIRED, THEY SEND OUT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND HOAXES.
AND NOW THE BOOMERANG OF JUSTICE
IS IN FULL MOTION.
WE START TONIGHT, A BREAKING
REPORT FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
WHICH MIGHT HAVE ACTUALLY GOTTEN
SOMETHING STRAIGHT FOR A CHANGE,
AMAZING, THEY EVEN SAID WOW, THE
DOSSIER MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION, THE
ONE HILLARY PLAYED FOR, BUT
ACCORDING TO THE PAPER, THERE
NEWS TONIGHT, DEEP STATE SPYING
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DID
OCCUR, A LITTLE LATE, BUT IN A
BIG WAY.
THE HEADLINE READS "THE FBI SENT
INVESTIGATOR POSING AS ASSISTANT
TO MEET WITH TRUMP AID IN 2016."
THE ARTICLE DETAILS A LONDON
MEETING BETWEEN A FEMALE FBI
INVESTIGATOR WORKING UNDERCOVER,
A CAMBRIDGE PROFESSOR, AND A
FOREIGN POLICY EXPERT NAMED
STEFAN HALPER.
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS.
AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, HE SPENT
TWO WEEKS IN JAIL.
THE MEET UP WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
FOREIGN POLICY STRATEGY SESSION.
THE UNDERCOVER INVESTIGATOR,
WELL, SET UP THE MEETING.
HE WAS WORKING AS A SECRET FBI
INFORMANT, AND THEY BOTH WORKED
IN UNISON TO SPY ON PAPADOPOULOS
TO SET THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN UP.
"THE CONVERSATION AT A LONDON
BAR IN SEPTEMBER 2016 TOOK A
STRANGE TURN WHEN THE WOMAN
SITTING ACROSS FROM GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS ASKED A DIRECT
QUESTION: WAS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WORKING WITH RUSSIA?
KEEP IN MIND HALPER WAS ALSO SET
UP, MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AID CARTER PAGE, AND
WHO IS BEING WIRETAPPED.
ANOTHER WAY THEY SPIED ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN BY THE FBI AFTER
THE FBI DIRECTOR, COMEY, AND
OTHERS OBTAINED THE FISA WARRANT
USING HILLARY CLINTON'S
OPPOSITION RESEARCH WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" NOW
SUGGESTING COULD BE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, THE PHONY,
UNVERIFIED DOSSIER, THE DIRTY,
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
WOW, IT IS ALL BEGINNING TO COME
INTO FOCUS, AS I HAVE BEEN
PREDICTING.
NONE OF THESE SPYING SESSIONS
YIELDED ANY EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION, BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION PAID
WITHOUT A DOUBT, SPYING, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S RIGHT, DID
OCCUR.
IN THE HEIGHT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION UNDER THE BIDEN-OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WATCH, AGAIN, AN
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE, WHO
KNEW WHAT WHEN?
WE WILL GET THOSE ANSWERS
EVENTUALLY.
TONIGHT, DEMOCRATS ARE PRETTY
DETACHED FROM REALITY.
ANYTHING FROM HERE ON IN, IT IS
NOISE.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE -- THEY
COULDN'T HANDLE THE ELECTION
LOSS, THEY CAN HANDLE NO
COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
BUT IT IS OVER.
WATCH THEM ANYWAY.
>> IN THE ENTIRETY OF YOUR
PREVIOUS CAREER IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, INCLUDING
US ATTORNEY GENERAL, HAVE YOU
EVER REFERRED TO AUTHORIZED
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATIVE
ACTIVITIES, OFFICIALLY OR
PUBLICLY, AS "BUYING?"
I'M NOT ASKING FOR A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE USE OF THE WORD SPYING.
MY FIRST JOB WAS IN THE CIA, I
DON'T THINK THE WORD SPYING HAS
ANY PEJORATIVE CONNOTATION AT
ALL APPEAR THE QUESTION IS
ALWAYS WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
AUTHORIZED AND ADEQUATELY
PREDICATED.
I THINK SPYING IS A GOOD ENGLISH
WORD THAT, IN FACT, DOESN'T HAVE
SYNONYMS BECAUSE IT IS THE
BROADEST WORD INCORPORATING
REALLY ALL FORMS OF COVERT
INTELLIGENCE COLLECTION.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO BACK OFF THE
WORD SPYING.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THANK GOD
FOR THE GREAT INTELLIGENCE
OFFICERS THAT SERVE WE THE
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PROTECTING US EVERY
DAY, THE 99%, THANK GOD FOR THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD, THE FBI.
THE 99%.
TONIGHT, THOUGH, WE KNOW THE
DEEP STATE AGGRESSIVELY SPIED ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DURING AND
AFTER THE ELECTION.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER.
THAT IS WHAT WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE,
AND IF WE DON'T GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT, WE LOSE THE
COUNTRY.
NO SIGN THAT THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN BASED ANY SIMILAR
SCRUTINY, EVEN THOUGH, AS IT
TURNS OUT, WELL, THERE WAS A
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE THAT
CLINTON AND THE DNC MORE THAN
ONCE -- PAY CLOSE ATTENTION --
TRYING TO COLLUDE WITH FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME, JUST LOOK
AT WHAT THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY
CONFIRMED TO "THE HILL"'S JOHN
SOLOMON, WHO JOINS US WITH A
MINUTE.
BUMPS ON THE REPORT FROM HIM,
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE ACCUSING A
CONTRACTOR OF ATTEMPTING TO
COLLUDE WITH THEIR GOVERNMENT,
SAYING THAT SHE "SOUGHT
INFORMATION FROM THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT ON PAUL MANAFORT'S
DEALINGS INSIDE THE COUNTRY IN
THE HOPES OF FORCING THE ISSUE
BEFORE CONGRESS.
ACCORDING TO THE AMBASSADOR'S
OFFICE, SHE ALSO "TRIED TO
ARRANGE FOR THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT TO COMMENT ON MENA
FORD'S TIES DURING THE U.S. 2016
CAMPAIGN."
COMES AFTER THE COURT FOUND THAT
THEY SOUGHT TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD MARK THE
ELECTION, AND IT ADMISSION FROM
BRUCE OHR THAT UKRAINIAN
LAWMAKER WAS FEEDING PHONY,
ANTI-TRUMP DIRT TO FUSION GPS,
THE FIRM THAT BRUCE OHR'S WIFE
WORKED FOR, RESPONSIBLE FOR THE